c'est l'heure de notre second débat avec
cette question vous sentez-vous parfois
saturé d'un four ras-le-bol des alertes
sur les réseaux sociaux des polémiques
en boucle sur les chaînes d'information
continue vous souffrez peut-être de
fatigue informationnelle le phénomène a
été identifié étudié par la Fondation
Jean Jaurès et l'opso avant d'en
débattre avec mes invités on découvre
les grandes lignes de cette étude de ce
rapport grâce à Cécile Sixou si vous
vivez de plus en plus mal les alertes
médias sur votre téléphone les infos ont
continué à la télé ou encore la lecture
du journal ou souffrez peut-être de
fatigue informationnelle un trop-plein
d'actualité qui touche aujourd'hui plus
d'un Français sur deux selon une étude
de la Fondation Jean Jaurès et qui
impacte de plus en plus leur santé
stressée angoissé déprimé les Français
trop informés sont aussi dépendants de
l'actualité on produit de l'information
à la chaîne dans un espèce de flux
permanent qui fait que et ben on est
tous un peu comme des souris dans un
dans un tambour de machine à laver et on
tourne on tourne en permanence on a
envie d'en savoir plus toujours en
permanence et c'est ça crée une un
rapport addictif finalement à
l'information un rapport de drogué
quelque part et comme pour
l'alimentation on a du mal à retrouver
une nutrition plus plus responsable
journaux télé radio réseaux sociaux
podcasts les canaux d'information se
sont diversifiés aujourd'hui les
Français utilisent en moyenne 8 supports
différents pour s'informer dont trois
quotidiennement les plus populaires sont
la radio pour 46% des Français les JT
pour 55% et les réseaux sociaux en tête
pour 62%, une évolution inquiétante car
contrairement aux idées reçues ce qui
utilise et maîtrise le mieux les réseaux
sociaux les jeunes urbains diplômés ne
sont pas les plus protégés
finalement des réseaux sociaux de cet
univers informationnel ou tout va vite
ou une information chasse l'autre et
ainsi de suite les codes et ils peuvent
nous montrer le chemin et en fait c'est
l'inverse qui se produit c'est à dire
que ils sont très fatigués ils ne savent
pas hiérarchiser l'information ils se
déclarent en difficulté justement pour
pour s'informer et donc il y a quelque
chose de très très important là-dessus
c'est à dire que c'est quand même
l'avenir c'est les prochains les
prochains décideurs de notre pays et
eux-mêmes se disent bah en fait on peut
pas décider faire le tri des
informations limiter les temps d'écran
ou encore réguler les flux une manière
de se protéger de la fatigue
informationnelle sans couper le robinet
car pour 59% des Français s'informer
restent importants
on analyse ce phénomène on esquisse des
solutions aussi grâce à mes invités
Ganael Go bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
directrice générale de l'opsoco
l'Observatoire société et consommation
et vous avez avec la Fondation Jean
Jaurès et Arte travailler à cette à
cette étude haute Carrasco bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes chef de la rubrique
média chez le quotidien Lacroix je veux
faire de la Croix Georges Vigarello
bonne soirée bienvenue au soir historien
directeur d’études à l'École des hautes
études en sciences sociales et auteur de
l'histoire de la fatigue du Moyen-Âge à
nos jours aux éditions du Seuil Laetitia
cruppa évidemment est resté à mes côtés
je redonne quelques chiffres on en a eu
plusieurs dans dans le sujet de Cécile
mais le chiffre global 53% des Français
qui disent souffrir de fatigue
informationnelle et puis si on rentre un
peu dans le détail à la question vous
sentez-vous stressé ou épuisé par un
trop-plein d'informations on trouve
finalement
50% qui disent régulièrement et de temps
en temps et puis 49% qui disent rarement
ou jamais c'est plutôt partagé face à
cette question Ganael Go je commence
avec vous est-ce que ce phénomène il est
lié à un événement à une actualité un
événement ou une succession d'événements
moi la première réaction ça a été ça ça
a été de me dire il y a eu la crise
covid la guerre et ça et ça explique
finalement une partie des phénomènes
est-ce que vous ressentez ça vous dans
l'étude alors je pense que ce qu'on ce
qu'on voit c'est pas tellement
dur c'est plutôt notre notre
conscientisation ou notre réflexivité à
propos de ça qui elle s'est déclarée
mais en fait c'est une tectonique des
plaques en fait on voit progresser ça
alors on en parlera sans doute mais avec
un changement de l'écosystème médiatique
évidemment on voit on voit progresser ça
enfin il suffit de rappeler il y a 10
ans il y avait pas un Français sur cinq
qui était sur les réseaux sociaux
aujourd'hui c'est deux tiers des
Français et on voit que c'est le média
le plus enfin en tout cas les
plateformes les plus utilisées pour
aller s'informer mais donc ça s'est
installé sourdement comme beaucoup aussi
de changements importants et puis ça
s'est révélé à certains moments et
notamment nous on l'observait parce
qu'on a suivi par exemple pendant la
crise covid pendant deux ans quasiment
on a suivi au jour le jour un panel de
50 français et puis on les interrogeait
aussi par des enquêtes plus plus
quantitatives et on voyait les Français
nous dire je suis en train de changer un
peu la ma façon de faire avec
l'information s'interroger et se dire je
suis stressé qu'est-ce que je peux faire
pour me protéger par rapport en fait à
toute l'actualité qui était devenue très
répétitive très centrée autour du covid
est très anxiogène donc ils ont changé
leur vie scientifique qui a été
fragilisée en grande partie par cette
crise pas notre aussi
tourne vers des vers des choses
informations exactement et puis il y a
eu les débats sur les fake news est
toujours
il se cachait aussi quelque chose
derrière c'est à dire que les sur les
fake news enfin sur la fatigue
informationnelle qu'on a donc essayé de
mesurer les fake news aussi prennent
appui là-dessus finalement naissent un
peu de de cela autre cas est-ce que
c'est presque un retour d'expérience que
je vous propose de partager pour ouvrir
ce débat quand vous avez découvert ce
phénomène qu'est-ce que vous faites à la
croix vous lancez un appel à témoin
c'est ça le point de départ c'est vrai
que c'est en faisant cette enquête que
j'ai découvert le terme fatigue
informationnelle qui est vraiment
maintenant de rentrer dans le débat
public grâce à la à l'étude de Bosco et
de la fête de la Fondation Jean Jaurès
alors à l'époque ce qui me ce qui
interroge chaque année la croix publie
un baromètre de confiance dans les
médias et quand on en parle on a beau
voilà on parle beaucoup de la confiance
envers les différents médias mais il y a
un autre indicateur important que
j'observais depuis deux ou trois ans et
qui me paraissait assez inquiétant c'est
cet intérêt pour l'information qui
pendant très longtemps été à plus de 75
76% des gens qui se déclaraient avoir de
s'intéresser beaucoup enfin
s'intéressait beaucoup beaucoup enfin
c'est intéressant ça a commencé à chuter
quelques années
malgré des présidentielles malgré quand
même ça attire monté un peu pendant un
crise sanitaire mais c'était 67% alors
que cette information était tellement
utile vitale pour tout à chacun et donc
le dernier baromètre on était arrivé à
62% ça paraissait quand même encore
c'était retombé et donc il y a des
témoignages qui arrivent très vite quand
vous lancez ça s'appelle c'est que voilà
c'est l'idée c'était de savoir qui qui
sont ces personnes et puis peut-être
comment l'information du coup leur
arrive est-ce qu'il s'informe plus du
tout très peu et l'idée ça a été de
lancer en fait un appel à témoignage
à des personnes qui s'étaient voilà leur
demander où vous étiez vous aviez
l'habitude de de suivre plusieurs médias
il y a un moment vous avez ressenti le
besoin de couper le robinet de
l'information voilà je m'attendais à bon
j'ai commencé par le lancer sur Twitter
je voulais le lancer sur d'autres
réseaux sociales et en fait j'ai été il
y a eu vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de
personnes qui m'ont répondu se sont
reconnus dans son reconnu et je
m'attendais je mettais un petit peu
blindée je m'attendais quand même à une
critique des médias etc créer un
dialogue par rapport voilà une critique
qu'on peut à laquelle on peut s'attendre
sur les réseaux sociaux et en fait
légitime d'ailleurs voilà totalement
légitime et j'ai plutôt perçu
une sensation de
la submersion c'est à dire de la cette
perte de contrôle par rapport à
l'information qui nous submergeait qu'on
a que le cerveau n'arrivait plus
vraiment à traiter de le caractère
anxiogène aussi qui faisait que
les citoyens se sentaient vraiment mal
c'était parfois même pour la santé
mentale et aussi des dissonances
cognitives aussi plus en fonction des
aspirations par rapport à des
préoccupations transition écologique et
en tout cas un lien un lien avec
l'information enfin une culpabilité un
mal-être par rapport à cette information
qui est importante et en fait oui je
pensais aller dans des vers des
personnes qui se détournaient de
l'information et c'est là avec cette
appétence que j'ai découvert ce
phénomène de la enfin j'ai découvert en
tout cas les cavistes cette existence ce
phénomène de la news fatigue en en et
pays anglo-saxon qui avait été très
présent notamment au moment du brexit et
au moment de l'élection de Trump c'est à
dire des moments où
un phénomène que avec qui prend des
racines quand même et qui et qui
existaient depuis longtemps et ce qui
est intéressant et je me tourne vers
vous Georges vulgarello c'est que c'est
pas la première fois notre histoire que
il y a alors mon employait sans doute
pas ce terme-là mais il y a cette
fatigue informatique je crois que cette
enquête de toute façon mais en évidence
quelque chose qui est absolument
passionnant et qui est fondamental avec
un terme nouveau fatigue informationsnel
c'est extrêmement parlant et je pense
qu'en plus ça correspond deux faits à
quelque chose qui a changé c'est très
bien montrer les réseaux sociaux
l'accumulation de l'information cette
merveilleuse phrase de Edgar Morin qui
montre que l'excès d'informations tue
l'information ça c'est absolument
magnifique mais ce qui est intéressant
quand on se retourne un petit peu vers
l'histoire c'est de constater que
lorsqu'il y a des changements forts dans
les modes d'information et dans l'entour
si vous voulez il y a des phénomènes
nouveaux et en particulier des fenêtres
de fatigue je prends un exemple très
simple mais c'est pas le seul mais je
prends un exemple très simple à partir
du moment où la société de la fin du 19e
siècle devient une société où il y a une
presse quotidienne où il y a des
informations qui portent de plus en plus
sur des phénomènes que je qualifierai
d'affectif de crime
de danger etc même les périodiques
hebdomadaires vous voyez le petit
journal avec les images de crime sur la
la première page etc avec le sentiment
aussi que le monde s'accélère les
vitesses les trains le téléphone le
télégraphe bref vous avez à la fin du
19e siècle un certain nombre de
personnes qui disent le monde me déborde
le monde me dépasse et vous avez un mot
nouveau exactement comme informe la
fatigue informationnelle est un mot
nouveau vous avez à la fin du 19e siècle
à mon nouveau qui est le mode surmenage
c'est à dire qu'ensemble de Jean se
disent surmener trop d'activités trop
d'informations impossibilité de réponse
et ça je trouve que c'est très
intéressant historiquement c'est le
parallèle il est face le même phénomène
le parallèle est fort et en même temps
je pense que le parallèle il faut le
tirer pour essayer de montrer que c'est
quand même pas la même chose alors c'est
pas la même chose parce que le mode
d'information renvoie par exemple à la
saturation de l'information au sens
étroit du terme l'écran l'écran qui dit
trop etc mais je pense qu'il faut
ajouter quelque chose qui me paraît
personnellement assez centrale que j'ai
essayé de travailler dans l'histoire de
la fatigue c'est quoi c'est que en même
temps entre le 19e et aujourd'hui les
individus me semblent avoir acquis plus
d'autonomie psychologique je veux pas
dire d'autonomie forcément réelle mais
ils ont le sentiment que l’antonomie
s'est accentué et en même temps cette
autonomie elle peut pas vers isolant
s'affirmer parce qu'elle est débordée
par l'information et de surcoings cette
autonomie par certains côtés elle est
menacée parce que vous avez évidemment
des gens qui viennent prendre du pouvoir
sur ce que vous faites parce que la
consommation vous dit il faut faire ça
et ça et vous perdez en quelque sorte
quelque chose qui est de l'ordre de
votre propre initiative et je pense que
cette perte de votre propre initiative
joue dans le sentiment de fatigue vous
voyez et donc du coup c'est assez
complexe comme question et c'est ça qui
l'a rend passionnante et une fois encore
moi vraiment je trouve que c'était cette
étude est absolument décisive et on va
continuer évidemment de la det je vous
propose un premier témoignage puisé dans
l'émission dialogue citoyen 8 octobre
dernier sur notre antenne Isabelle
grande consommatrice d'actualité qui
alors je vais parler des événements elle
date sa fatigue informationnelle des
attentats de 2015
vraiment les attentats ont
marqué terriblement alors que je n'avais
aucune raison on va dire
je n'avais pas été touché directement
donc
j'étais justement à ce moment-là en
plein bilan de compétences je me fais
plusieurs dans ma vie et
grâce à ça d'ailleurs j'ai été
accompagné et avec le recul je voilà je
peux dire que c'est depuis les attentats
que j'ai enfin vraiment décidé
d'arrêter cette pollution c'était un
stress qui ne m'appartenait pas c'est à
dire que c'était quelque chose
qui me polluait mais qui ne me
nourrissait pas
alors on va peut-être pas être sur le
les attentats moi ce que je retiens
aussi c'est grandes consommatrice
d'actualité c'est comme ça qu'elle se
définit est-ce que ceux qui se disent
aujourd'hui saturés étaient forcément
des grands consommateurs d'actualité ou
pas
car ceux qui se disent
aujourd'hui sont ceux qui justement ont
un rapport très désignant par rapport à
l'information on vit de s'informer et on
voit il y a notamment dans notre étude
de groupe un groupe ou justement ce sont
les plus jeunes les plus diplômés les
plus connectés qui ont un rapport avec
l'information qui a changé parce que
c'est un rapport comme comme vous le
disiez c'est à dire c'est dans
l'écosystème informationnel on a aussi
une forme de le centre de gravité est
allé plus vers l'individu qui doit
orchestrer sa propre information qui
voit on est tous vecteurs d'informations
sur nos médias sociaux dans nos boucles
WhatsApp avec les idées etc
ils sont particulièrement fatigués et
c'est effectivement un peu un peu
dangereux de les voir tenter parfois de
de s'en retirer et puis un autre groupe
aussi qui est un peu borderline c'est à
dire c'est c'est un groupe qui est plus
un peu plus âgé un peu plus féminin un
peu plus modeste aussi qu'il y a envie
de s'informer mais qui se sont débordés
incapables submerger ne pas avoir la
maîtrise et qui du coup en train d'en
nourrir une forme de défiance et une
forme de défiance aussi vis-à-vis ça
pour le coup ça décapite
de même le plus souvent alors que il y a
des groupes qui sont pas fatigués mais
parce qu'ils s'informent beaucoup moins
il y a des groupes qui sont pas fatigués
parce qu'ils ont déjà une telle défiance
ils sont sortis ce qui est tout aussi
inquiétant c'est-à-dire c'est
intéressant de voir ceux qui sont
fatigués et les autres aussi les autres
groupes donc on voit bien que il y a un
rapport comme ça global à l'information
qui est en question Georges Vigarello il
y a cette notion de fatigue parce que
vous avez parlé des écrans mais c'est
une fatigue émotionnelle ça rejoint un
peu le témoignage c'est-à-dire que même
si les attentats de 2015 n'ont pas
personnellement touché elle s'est sentie
personnellement touchée
avant de avant de retrouver aujourd'hui
vous avez très bien à la fin du 19e des
réactions face à la presse qui vous
disent mais comment je peux résister
face à des émotions qui sont toujours
différentes et qui d'un jour à l'autre
me portent à une sensibilité autre si
vous voulez donc vous avez ça déjà mais
ici ce qui me
propre autonomie etc je veux pas
systématiser mais ça me paraît très
important et ça et ça c'est évidemment
facteur de fatigue mais cette fatigue
elle aussi est originale parce qu'elle
est psychologique effectivement
émotionnelle ou psy ou psychologique au
Carrasco ce lien entre la fatigue
informationnelle et les réseaux sociaux
les médias sociaux dans votre enquête il
ressort il ressort très très clairement
totalement c'est le premier média que
les gens qui se disent fatigués
émotionnellement site ou pas forcément
alors effectivement c'est j'ai eu
beaucoup de jeunes en fait de
trentenaires et eux s'informaient
particulièrement sur sur les réseaux
sociaux sur tous les modes mais
sociaux jusqu'à une forme de ouais de
saturation de mal-être
et voilà ils ont beaucoup ressenti le
besoin de vraiment mettre à distance ce
mode d'information pour retrouver
pour retrouver un contrôle en fait
quelque part dans l'information en all
des podcasts ou des newsletters
qui vont faire que l'information est
utile qu'elle répond à une préoccupation
qu'elle est utile pour le citoyen quel
utile pour la vie de tous les jours
c'est intéressant guenalgo parce que il
y a deux phénomènes il y a le phénomène
de je veux rien louper et ça c'est c'est
ce qui c'est l'une des explications du
succès des réseaux sociaux des médias
sociaux c'est de voilà de d'être au
courant de tout ce qui se passe que ce
soit dans son cercle proche ou à l'autre
bout de la planète et puis il y a je le
moment où à force de vouloir rien louper
on retient plus rien quoi c'est c'est ce
qui est exprimé Fomo là la peur de
louper missing out et puis il y a aussi
le fait d'avoir du mal à s'empêcher de
cliquer à peu près enfin voilà et ça ça
me semble intéressant parce que il y a
un un autre sujet c’est-à-dire on est
dans une société de l'information
aujourd'hui et il y a une économie en
fait de l'attention c'est ce qui
explique très bien Yves sitton qui dit à
un moment donné la ressourcera là qu'on
a aujourd'hui c'est l'attention des gens
c'est le fameux vous souvenez quart
d'heure le temps de cerveau disponible
demande ancien patron à TF1 Patrick
Bruel ça ça retourné un peu les les
choses et il y a une
compétition en fait pour notre attention
qui se joue avec parfois des des une
forme de pour le coup c'est Gérald
Brunner qui emploie ce terme de
démagogie cognitive c'est-à-dire on va
on va essayer d'attiser ce fameux
cerveau un qui est celui de l'émotion
qui est celui de la réaction qui est
celui de et on se laisse faire les gens
nous disent on se laisse faire plutôt
que le système 2 qui lui est réflexif et
mais voilà et c'est c'est très compliqué
en fait dans dans ce système là donc il
y a cette économie de l'attention à
laquelle et bien sûr là on est en train
de penser à substituer une forme
d'écologie en fait de de l'attention les
grands finalement de ce phénomène sont
les médias traditionnels nous-mêmes je
ne devrais pas d'ailleurs est-ce qu'on
pourrait on pourrait considérer qu'on
est à une contre et au contraire un lieu
de refuge en premier lieu oui je pense
que et d'ailleurs enfin c'est aussi pour
ça que on est enfin que cette que cette
enquête vous interpelle au premier chef
parce que elle interroge aussi et dans
cette écosystème c'est l'émetteur le
récepteur qui n'est plus très clair et
moi je pense qu'au contraire ça revitif
l'importance de de justement de
certifier de professionnels de
professionnels d'investigation de
réflexion
en tout cas c'est ce qu'on voit il y a
peut-être un premier temps où ça
perturbe et puis un deuxième temps ou
voilà ça reconstruit une forme de je
vais vous faire un aveu on a travaillé
ensemble dans une émission qui
s'appelait media le magazine sur sur
France 5 et quand j'ai démarré cette
émission c'était le début de la la
numérisation des des médias et cette
question elle commençait déjà à se poser
et moi j'étais persuadé que face
aux amorces à ce qui commençaient être
un mouvement de fake news ou de vérité
alternative etc etc ou d'informations
non contrôlée
les médias traditionnels justement avec
un un boulot bien fait par des police
une information certifiée sortirait du
lot et finirait par l'emporter ça met du
temps comment vous dire je pensais que
ça irait plus vite que ça et on y est
pas encore je sais j'espère que ça
arrivera mais j'espère ça c'est mon côté
petit j'espère que ça arrivera mais ça
met du temps je vous raconte propose à
Mathias de nous rejoindre tout de suite
pour peut-être faire un constat tout
simple Mathias rebonsoir sur l'évolution
de l'offre médiatique en France allez on
va commencer par une petite question
Thomas est-ce que vous connaissez
l'année du premier JT en France alors je
vais très honnête avec vous quand j'ai
lu votre chronique je me suis dit 48 et
puis après je suis allé vérifier je
crois que c'est 49 c'est 40 heures et
non il y avait pas de présentateur bon
de l'eau a coulé sous les ponts depuis
alors au-delà de la télévision c'est
bien le panorama médiatique qui a évolué
de manière quasiment exponentielle au
cours des dernières décennies
aujourd'hui en France on dénombre plus
de 4000 titres de presse écrite locale
régional national magazine et spécialisé
plus de 1500 radios avec les mêmes
déclinaisons 26 chaînes de une vision
gratuite avec la TNT mais aussi des
dizaines de chaînes locales et des
centaines par abonnement et puis enfin
des dizaines de pure players ces médias
100% numérique alors tous ne font pas de
l'information mais quand ils en font ils
font souvent la même information c'est
ça en tout cas ce que ce qu'on tenté de
prouver Julien kagé Marie-Luce viiot et
Nicolas Hervé dans leur livre
l'information à tout prix alors ils
appellent cela le risque croissant de
l'homogéné homogénéisation pardon alors
en réalité ce dont on s'aperçoit c'est
que pour une question de baisse de coûts
les médias ont de moins en moins recours
à la production originale d'information
alors les auteurs ont par exemple prouvé
qu'en moyenne le taux d'originalité d'un
article en ligne n'est que de 36% une
tendance au copier-coller donc que l'on
retrouve dans tous les médias et
notamment dans la reprise de ce qu'on
appelle les exclus alors là aussi Julia
Caget Marie-Luce vio et Nicolas Hervé
ont sorti leur calculette pour voir en
moyenne en combien de temps une
information a été récupérée par les
autres médias alors lorsque celle-ci est
donnée par une type AFP ils font environ
deux heures pour qu'elle se retrouve
chez la concurrence un peu moins de 4
heures lorsque c'est dans la presse
écrite 4 heures tout pile en télé un peu
plus de 4 heures pour la radio et loin
devant environ 7 heures pour un pur
Player et puis un autre thème un autre
sujet c'est la surexploitation d'une
information notamment depuis l'avènement
des chaînes d'infos absolument nous en
avons eu le triste exemple ces derniers
jours avec le traitement d'un fait
divers dont vous avez très certainement
tous entendu parler celui de l'affaire
Justine Veyrac cette jeune femme
assassinée en Corrèze un féminicide qui
malheureusement arrive souvent pourtant
les médias ayant particulier les chaînes
d'infos ont décidé de beaucoup couvrir
l'affaire alors nos confrères de
quotidien ont pris le temps de calculer
en l'espace de 4 jours seulement LCI en
a parlé 10 minutes France Info 1h45 loin
derrière cnews et ses 5 heures et
finalement largement en tête BFMTV et
c'est 22 heures d'antenne merci beaucoup
et on a là un peu de la des choix
éditoriaux de certains de nos de nos
confrères juste avant Justine il y avait
quand même l'affaire de la petite Lola
bien sûr
cette séquence on appelle ça dans les
médias la séquence des faits divers et
d'ailleurs on consacrera un débat de
seconde partie là encore volontairement
décalé de l'actualité vous aurez
remarqué qu'on n'a pas parlé de ces
affaires dans les premiers jours on
prend le temps la semaine prochaine on
fera un débat sur les faits divers leur
médiatisation leur poids éventuels
politiques haute Carrasco sur les moyens
je pense que c'est quelque chose qui est
important de rappeler une information de
qualité ça coûte cher oui ça coûte cher
et ça paye beaucoup moins c'est ce que
montrer l'étude de enfin scoop ne paye
plus beaucoup quoi le temps de de
d'utilisation par le média qui sort
l'information c'est ça très très court
parce que c'est repris par différents
médias même si ça sera pas approfondie
de la même façon etc donc c'est vrai que
c'est c'est un vrai choix éditorial en
fait une vraie un vrai investissement
éditorial et effectivement bon les
beaucoup de faire des débats avec
quelques intervenants ou notamment sur
des sujets clivants c'est pas cher ça
fait de l'audience donc ça participe
aussi à l'écosystème des radios des
réseaux sociaux ça nourrit les
algorithmes des réseaux sociaux qui vont
mettre en avant des propos polémiques et
clivant enfin voilà c'est un peu un
écosystème délétère et qui nuit à une
information de qualité et qui peut
détourner effectivement des citoyens
d'information quoi Georges Vigarello on
a peut-être jamais été aussi connecté
nous nous humains aussi bombardés
d'infos c'est à la fois une ouverture
sur le monde que les habitants de
certaines dictatures nous nous envient
mais on l'a évoqué il y a cette
incapacité matérielle à faire le tri à
la fatigue je voudrais revenir sur ce
que vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure mais
à mon avis trop rapidement sur les
écrans parce que c'est ça participe de
cette fatigue quand on voit un écran
surchargé de d'infos de Bordeaux
d'images d'alerte etc mais je suis
sensible parce que vous dites parce que
écran c'est un très bel exemple qui
porte sur la charge mentale quel est le
taux d'information qui se trouve sur
l'écran que vous pouvez arriver à
maîtriser et engranger donc ça c'est une
question que je qualifierais de quasi
intellectuelle mais qui est très
important il y a des calculs évidemment
il y a des calculs qui portent sur la
maîtrise à non maîtrise le le taux ça
change mental si vous voulez et en même
temps ce que nous avons dit qui me
paraît très important c'est que d'un
côté vous avez cette question de change
mentale s'il y a qu'est-ce qu'elle est
le flux que vous pouvez arriver à
maîtriser et on le retrouve d'ailleurs
dans des questions professionnelles si
vous voulez le la personne qui se trouve
devant un écran et qui doit interpréter
les signes qui lui sont envoyés pour les
répercuter quelque part il faut qu'elle
puisse maîtriser le nombre de signes
qu'on lui envoie donc c'est une question
très importante qui a des effets quasi
économiques et puis il y a la deuxième
question qui a été abordé à plusieurs
reprises ici qui me paraît très
importante c'est la question des réseaux
sociaux parce que dans le réseau social
au-delà de ce que pourrait appeler la
technique du flux informationnel au-delà
ça vous avez la secte et c'est la fête à
mon avis qui devient aujourd'hui de plus
en plus important et qui entraîne dans
certains cas là non maîtrise et qui
entraîne l'affectue nous essaie donc ça
donne deux catégories de questions qui
ne sont pas les mêmes et celles qui
portent son réseau sociaux sur les
réseaux sociaux et qui est totalement
nouvelle c'est là et fondamental
est-ce que vous faites dans l'étude le
lien entre cette fatigue et la montée en
puissance du complotisme
pas directement c'est à dire que on fait
un lien de non on n'a pas encore testé
ça c'est des choses qu'on va on va
poursuivre on va poursuivre nos
investigations là-dessus et c'est vrai
mais c'est vrai qu'il y a des il y a des
corrélations c'est à dire que pour le
moment ce qu'on note si on est rigoureux
c'est pas un lien de cause à effet ou
c'est des relations qu'il y a entre
entre des données c'est à dire que ce
que l'on voit c'est que les plus fatigué
sont aussi parmi les plus défiants ceux
qui
enfin certains sont parmi les plus
défiants sont ceux qui vont
estimer que la démocratie fonctionne le
moins bien sont ceux qui vont papoyer à
être plus défiant aussi vise à l'égarder
de de des médias les gardes des
institutions donc en fait c'est ça en
fait qui inquiétant et peut-être même
qu'au-delà du complotisme moi je trouve
que le risque qui est réel pour pour la
démocratie mais le risque du retrait en
fait il est presque plus grave parce que
se dire à un moment donné ok comme il
nous le disent dans dans l'enquête
c'est-à-dire une forme d'A puisque ça
chauffe de toute façon c'est toujours
les mêmes infos de toute façon tout tout
va trop vite de toute façon on n'a pas
le temps donc on se risque du retrait ce
risque de se dire bon bah je laisse tout
à distance c'est aussi un risque de pour
la démocratie mais par défaut parce que
du coup on laisse le terrain en fait
occupé pour ceux qui vont être les plus
les plus les plus actifs quoi au cas où
c'est le l'objet de cette étude de la
Croix chaque année sur le lien de
confiance entre les Français et leur et
leur média il se il se distend
régulièrement
année après année
alors
non ça fait un oui oui si on regarde sur
une longue période si je prends mais
malheureusement bientôt 40 années de
carrière j'exagère un peu 35 allez en 35
ans il s'est il s'est sérieusement abîmé
ce lien
descendante il y a quand même des
évolutions
entre les différents types de médias
enfin on a vraiment vu ces derniers
moments enfin je sais plus enfin la
télévision après la crise sanitaire ou
avant la crise sanitaire
voilà il y avait eu des quel est notre
part de responsabilité puisque vous
l'analysez ça à nous journaliste à nous
médias alors c'est toujours compliqué de
faire un amalgame mais de danse dans la
perte de confiance
dans la perte de confiance c'est aussi
un tout un lien à retrouver parfois même
un lien un peu physique c'est-à-dire que
s'il faut interroger aussi c'est la
distribution de l'information qui se
fait de plus en plus par les réseaux
sociaux donc c'est une dés la médiation
on a même pu de contact direct voilà
c'est ça qui
pourquoi parce que finalement on a plus
un journal
physique papier qui a son identité entre
les mains c'est une page comme les
autres et finalement toutes les pages se
ressemblent que ce soit celle d'un média
on va dire traditionnel ou celle d'un
site qui ne fait que du copier-coller
c'est c'est un peu ça ce que je vous dis
c'est parce qu'on a la possibilité de
s'engager personnellement excusez-moi je
crois que c'est parce qu'on a la
possibilité de s'engager personnellement
et avec cette possibilité de s'engager
personnellement il y a de l'affect je
reviens à ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure
de toutes les contenus enfin je suis
désolé quand vous regardez en fonction
des chaînes d'infos certaines ont choisi
des sujets mais elles sont monolithiques
sur ces sujets depuis plusieurs mois on
pourrait en faire un débat il y a aussi
ce suivisme la peur peut-être d'être
pionnier le scoop ne paye plus vous
l'avez dit mais comme le voisin fait je
sais pas un sur cette histoire et ben on
va faire la même chose il y a vraiment
un problème dans l'écosystème des médias
traditionnels aujourd'hui mais qui qui a
très peut-être à des choix aussi
industriels à redistribuer les gens
autrement à remettre de l'argent dans
les enquêtes enfin il y a quand même
toute une remise en question à faire au
niveau journalistique à toute à tous les
niveaux de la hiérarchie journalistique
oui mais cela dit il y a un problème de
fond dont nous n'avons pas parlé qui est
vraiment un problème de fond à mes yeux
qui est de l'ordre de ce que
j'appellerai un gain et qui en même
temps et de l'ordre d'une perte alors je
m'explique qu'est-ce que c'est que le
gain le gain c'est le fait que les
individus je reviens à ce que je disais
s'affirme davantage se sentent de plus
en plus autonome et du coup comment vous
dire il s’écoute il s'écoute de plus en
plus et en s'écoutant de plus en plus le
moindre manque devient quelque chose qui
est difficile à supporter vous voyez il
y a un plus le fait de s'écouter de
s'enrichir d'être beaucoup plus
attentive de varier les possibilités
d'information d'être attentif dans les
dans les musées etc ça c'est un gain
magnifique et en même temps vous vous
écoutez et le moindre manque devient un
obstacle et je pense que ça s'ajoute
tout à l'heure où finalement on n'est
jamais rassasié parce qu'il nous
manquera toujours une info il y a aussi
le fait je pense qu'il y a un décalage
aussi et
un décalage qui peut être perçu par les
individus entre l'information telle que
la traite les médias et la réalité de
leur préoccupations et je sais que le
baromètre à bord aussi cette question
c'est-à-dire est-ce que est-ce que les
les journalistes les médias ont
suffisamment ou pas traité d'un certain
nombre de sujets et je fais le pari qu'à
la fin de l'année ils auront selon les
Français beaucoup traité de l'affaire
enfin de la disparition d'Elisabeth II
de la faire Lola par exemple
et ça c'est un paradoxe aussi de de ceux
qui nous regardent qui vont dans une
étude dire ah ben vous en avez trop fait
sur la mort de d'Elizabeth II ou
ce fait divers horrible de la mort la
petite là et puis qui en même temps les
regardent c'est ces éditions spéciales
et si nos confrères notamment sur les
sur les chaînes d'infos continuent ou
dans certains j'étais continuent de
beaucoup en parler c'est parce que les
téléspectateurs sont là oui alors c'est
vrai et il nous le disent aussi mais
parce qu'on envisage aussi l'audience
que de manière très quantitative et pas
de manière qualitative et là aussi ça
peut pas durer très longtemps c'est à
dire qu'il y a un moment où
effectivement c'est fait divers et
meuves et à juste titre mais en même
temps quand on regarde nous on mesure
par exemple les préoccupations des
Français en fait le débat que ça génère
derrière sur par exemple l'insécurité
sur l'immigration il est réel mais il
est réel pour une proportion très
réduite de français beaucoup plus
réduite que ce que donne à voir en tout
cas le débat médiatique en revanche la
question évidemment du pouvoir d'achat
mais la question du système de santé
arrive en seconde là depuis
sur en terme de préoccupation et
question de l'environnement ça c'est les
prix que préoccupations aussi assez
vives
également on pourrait aussi parler et
qui correspondrait plus à ce que vivent
les Français est-ce qu'ils ressentent
Laetitia on va se poser maintenant la
question du rôle de de l'école pour
moins de fatigue informationsnel une
meilleure instruction serait bénéfique
en fait je vous ai donné une idée de
futur enquête faites un sondage auprès
des enfants qui sont scolarisés
aujourd'hui comment ils arrivent à faire
la part déjà du vrai et du faux comment
ils arrivent à trouver la source d'une
information comment ils arrivent à
hiérarchiser la formation et je vous
parle de la primaire jusque jusqu'au bac
il y a en France en fait Thomas un
problème entre les textes et la pratique
parce que l'éducation aux médias et à
l'information est inscrite dans la loi
d'orientation pour la refondation de
l'école du 8 juillet 2013 donc ça va
faire 10 ans pourquoi les élèves n'en
bénéficient pas ou pas totalement
ici sur ce plateau peut-être que Lenny
c'est comme ça qu'on l'appelle
l'éducation aux la formation parce que
il reste un enseignement en fait
transversal c'est pas une discipline
scolaire donc souvent elle s'articule
dans différents dans différentes
matières par exemple la technologie ou
l'enseignement moral et civique on va en
fait parsemer comme ça un peu
d'enseignement aux médias un peu dans
tous les cours et finalement on se rend
compte que la responsabilité de cet
enseignement elle incombe et ça c'est
aussi une loi qui le dit aux
responsables des CDI vous savez ce
documentation
c'était comme ça que je disais mais bon
mais donc et c'est pas obligatoire le
CDI c'est à dire que peut-être qu'on
peut avoir une information mais enfin
c'est pas c'est pas obligatoire et il y
a aussi une circulaire qui a été publiée
en janvier 2022 qui stipule que chaque
recteur à l'obligation de désigner un
référent EMI en charge du premier et du
second degré alors pourquoi c'est pas
suffisant bah parce que on fait que
constater concrétisation un de ces
mesures sur le terrain par exemple la
circulaire de janvier demandait
l'installation du web radio dans tous
les collèges de France alors je ne sais
pas si vous avez des enfants en âge
d'être scolarisé au collège moi j'ai
fait une petite enquête personne n'a de
web radio dans son collège bon le plus
gros problème c'est bien sûr qu'il n'y a
pas encore une fois de cours spécifique
et donc les enfants qui sont les jeunes
et les adultes de demain seront
peut-être aussi ceux qui vont propager
les fake news parce qu'ils ne seront pas
faire la part des choses pour les
professeurs on leur a mis à disposition
une espèce de d'annulaire un peu comme
ça de l'EMI de l'enseignement des médias
et la formation où ils peuvent piocher
mais qui vous dit et qui contrôle aussi
le niveau de connaissance des
professeurs qui à leur tour ont à
enseigné aux élèves donc vous voyez
cette fatigue informationnelle elle
touche aussi les enseignants donc il y a
aucune raison pour que ils y arrivent
eux aussi à transmettre la bonne
information il y a bien sûr ça on le
sait parce que Public Sénat participe
des semaines d'informations ou des
professionnels nous-mêmes allons dans
les écoles expliquez la presse le
fonctionnement et la formation et il me
semble et je donne une petite piste que
il y aurait beaucoup de journalistes qui
seraient prêts à y aller plus de façon
plus fréquente pour informer les futurs
adultes autre Carrasco c'était éducation
médias c'est un enjeu qui dépasse
l'école qui qui concerne également les
adultes oui totalement
il y a toute une dimension effectivement
aujourd'hui de s'interroger alors
l'éducation le terme éducation aux
médias il y a un côté un peu
condescendant je sais pas c'est
initiation la production ou à la
participation au processus d'information
enfin je sais pas ce qu'il faudrait
inventer mais bon effectivement je
voudrais juste prendre la défense des
profs docs parce qu'il faut quand même
un boulot absolument remarquable et ils
sont très une force de proposition
importante bien sûr c'est pas
obligatoire et ça tient beaucoup
effectivement à des profs d'histoire des
profs français qui sont particulièrement
investies et il y a quand même de plus
en plus de liens avec des médias enfin
il y a beaucoup de dispositif qui se
sont développées et concernant
l'information effectivement le cette
éducation aux médias même si j'aime pas
ce terme qui pourrait s'adresser plus au
grand public il y a énormément de choses
à faire et un levier qui pourrait être
intéressant en fait c'est mieux
comprendre le fonctionnement de son
cerveau en fait ce fameux striateur qui
est insatiable et qui veut absolument
s'informer ne rien rater etc qui se
heurte à la conscience qui elle a besoin
de temps et d'attention et je pense
qu'une une sensibilisation
fonctionnement du cerveau peut être un
devis intéressant et être beau beaucoup
moins condescendant que une éducation
information tout en continuant à
expliquer parce qu'il y a une grosse
curiosité et puis c'est une façon
d'intéresser le public à la façon tout
simplement dont on fait des enquêtes on
fabrique l'information on réfléchit à
l'éditorial effectivement parler des
réseaux sociaux le gros problème des
réseaux sociaux c'est que notre
éditorial ou
tout est réfléchi entre voilà entre la
première page la deuxième page est
totalement segmentée quoi et en plus les
gens enfin beaucoup de personnes comme
l'information est de plus en plus
payante et notamment en France ne vont
se limiter qu'à qu'au titre et à
l'accroche et quand on a une information
un petit peu qui n'est pas complète
notre cerveau a tendance à
fabriquer à bouger les trous à boucher
les trous c'est une tendance du cerveau
je pense que ça peut être un levier
intéressant de sensibiliser quelques
minutes malheureusement c'est passé trop
vite sur les solutions on a commencé à
les à les aborder les uns et les autres
mais alors dans le dans votre étudecco
formation Jean Jaurès il y a la
déconnexion avec cette question vous
arrive-t-il de désactiver les
notifications sur votre téléphone
portable donc là c'est vraiment le la
partie du de l'étude sur le la
déconnexion
donc la réponse c'est jamais 25% 22% et
puis c'est assez équilibré de temps en
temps 26% régulièrement 27%, et si on
parle de la télévision là vous
arrivez-t-il de vous forcer à ne pas
allumer la télé alors là c'est beaucoup
moins partagé le ceux qui disent jamais
ou rarement ils sont très très loin de
ventre 38 % jamais 32%
rarement qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait dire
genre je vais garer l'eau choisissez vos
médias moi c'est ce que je dis souvent à
des amis c'est qui me disent on est
paumés on sait pas bah voilà vous avez
un ou deux médias dans lesquels vous
avez confiance la même payé parce qu'on
parle d'information gratuite c'est pas
non plus la solution on l'a vu
abonnez-vous et faites leur conscience
on se rend bien compte que c'est une
question extrêmement complexe mais je
pense qu'il y a une responsabilité des
parents aussi et il y a diffusé auprès
des parents le sentiment qu'ils ont une
responsabilité vis-à-vis de la façon
dont les enfants sont placés devant les
écrans ça c'est un premier point il y a
une deuxième point moi je pense que il y
a je disais tout à l'heure j'insistais
tout à l'heure sur l'écoute je crois
qu'il y a une façon
d'aider les personnes à s'écouter pour
savoir à partir de quel seuil je reviens
à ce qui a été dit tout à l'heure la
coupure peut-être faite voyez là il y a
saturation
et je voudrais quand même dire je vous
joins sur le problème du cerveau mais je
voudrais quand même dire pour défendre
quand même des enseignants je trouve que
les travaux faits par les historiens
sont plus nombreux qui ne l'était
auparavant sur les questions de l'image
vous voyez la question de la façon dont
l'image peut traverser la réalité la
façon dont les discours peuvent
installer quelque chose qui est dans du
faux et là il me semble que les profs
d'histoire
sont plus à même qu'il ne l'était
auparavant de réagir face à ces
questions là et donc personnellement
j'ai tendance à les soutenir
c'est bien évidemment il faut le faire
gagner Go un dernier mot peut-être sur
le ce qu'on appelle le journalisme de
solution c'est à dire de cellule des
critiques qui est souvent faite et
peut-être que c'est lié à la fatigue
internationale c'est trop d'infonctionne
que du négatif ça c'est une critique que
nous le journaliste on entend très
souvent est-ce que voilà le fait de
mettre en avant autre chose que les
mauvaises nouvelles pour vous c'est une
solution
peut-être la réalité plus encore de ce
que vivent les gens c'est à dire que et
même un vocabulaire parfois parce que
dans l'étude moi ce que j'ai trouvé
aussi intéressant c'est que les gens
nous disent qu'ils comprennent pas
toujours quand vous parlez et c'est vrai
prenez un exemple par exemple quand vous
dites place Beauvau c'est un nom de code
quoi tout le monde sait pas que c'est le
ministère de l'Intérieur et donc revenir
à ça revenir à des choses qui qui leur
parle à la vie on voit bien aussi par
exemple que la presse quotidienne
régionale qui est très ancrée sur le
local elle où on peut pas trop non plus
se permettre parce qu'on est très près
des gens donc il faut et ben elle elle a
une forme de crédibilité parce que
justement elle parle de la vie des gens
merci beaucoup c'est passé trop vite
mais c'est bon signe merci d'avoir
participé à ce débat Georges gigare
hello je rappelle le titre de votre
livre Histoire de la fatigue du
Moyen-Âge à nos jours c'est publié aux
éditions du Seuil voilà on espère ne pas
trop
participer à votre fatigue informations
professionnels en laissant du temps à
nos experts pour décortiquer l'actualité
et les thèmes beaucoup plus sociétaux
voilà je vous dis à lundi et puis demain
votre prochain rendez-vous rien de
Mancini reçoit le réalisateur
marseillais auberghedigan il viendra
parler Arménie politique et aussi de
cinéma forcément belle soirée
[Musique]